oh hi everyone and welcome to another
episode of Game life this week we are
taking a field trip to the Vita Hill
social club and event space right here
in San Francisco where Sony is pimping
its brand new handheld the PlayStation
Vita but first let's take a look at this
week's big news you may know video game
designer Jordan mech nur best for his
life's work prince of persia the series
that spends several acclaimed video
games graphic novels and a feature film
starring my close personal friend jake
gyllenhaal what you may not know unless
you were a big apple too or commodore 64
junkie back in the day is that Jordan
vectors first breakout success was a
1984 game called karateka and if you
haven't heard of that maybe it's because
you always used to mispronounce it kara
tika Oh does it ring a bell now designed
and programmed by mec nur in his dorm
room when he was an undergrad at Yale
University this silent film style tale
of karate master and his quest to rescue
the captive princess mary coe first
showed off mech nurse I for fluid
animation and cinematography last week
met near announced he's working on the
first ever follow up to karateka a
remake for the xbox 360 and playstation
3 in an interview with wired mech nurse
said of the new downloadable game that
he's creating a stylized vision of
medieval Japan that he could never have
dreamed of on the Apple to mec nurse
says the new karateka will be released
later this year and now it's time for a
field trip we are here in the marina one
of the fanciest places in san francisco
where you can get all kinds of french
stores things i have no idea i'm
actually here as you might imagine to
get a bikini wax but before that happens
i figured i would stop in to the vita
hill social club here which is where
Sony is showing off its new handheld
PlayStation Vita and I am about to
become an exclusive member of this very
exclusive club
hey welcome to the beautiful social club
thank you so much for becoming a member
this is awesome look at this I am so
famous that they gave me a membership
card just when I walked in the door for
nothing Oh sir everyone gets to become a
member okay but not everyone gets one of
these awesome prize redemption codes
right oh and everyone gives doin codes
20 so oh ok fair enough i didn't
actually win a prize but if I had won a
prize I'd get a key which I could use to
open up one of these boxes but you know
what I bet this whole thing is rigged
that nobody actually wins anyway uh what
you won no we didn't win yet uh oh man
no I want that shot glass hey come on
famous video game journalists coming
through well I could enjoy a PlayStation
3 game at no I believe I'll have the
complimentary coconut water and a side
of sound shapes man sound shapes is
awesome huh oh hey look guys it's dawn
miss her from Sony nice club you have
here done right thank you what's up what
was the point of putting together a
social club of this nature for the
PlayStation Vita launch well you know
the PlayStation Vita itself is really a
social gaming device and we just stopped
that you know this is a great place to
let people try out all of the games that
we have I really bring their friends
hang out here have a good time I mean
you're doing a whole lot of different
events and things like that at this but
right we sure are we just had a we had a
bet with Capcom they showed off Ultimate
Marvel vs. Capcom 3 here and in fact
would have another event we hosted by
playboy what uh Joe Garcia's gonna come
in here on plane first who's Joe Garcia
oh she just happens to be one of people
and it it's just right now it's
happening on 21st right right before
when we launched we're coming out every
20 seconds every 20 seconds ladies need
a PlayStation Vita man can't believe
they didn't have me there in the day the
Playboy Playmate was gonna be here whoo
well luckily I'm still the most
attractive person in the room well you
know you can only come back I could
always come back thanks reg you want
people to come back right bring your
friends have a good time here got snacks
we've got coconut water
stuff here oh yeah there is a lot of
coconut water and did notice that well I
gotta have a crash do this you gotta
begin well of course well that was fun
now as I said I've got a full Kojak to
get you down the street so my time here
at the Vita Hill social club has come to
an end but if you're lucky you might
still be able to catch one of these
pop-up shops in 82 written cities across
the United States and that's our show
everybody until next time you can find
us at wired.com / game life or follow me
on twitter at co boon heat see you next
time